The upcoming Game of Thrones prequel series,
House of the Dragon, is based on the George
RR Martin's Targaryen history book Fire & Blood.
House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
In other words it covers events from Aegon's
Conquest to the Dance of the Dragons.
Thats Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Vlood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
But back to Aegon's Conquest.
King Torrhen Stark, also known as the King
Who Knelt, was a head of House Stark who reigned
as King in the North when Aegon I Targaryen
invaded Westeros with his dragons and started
the War of Conquest.
Unlike every other king in Westeros, the King
in the North refused to fight Aegon but instead
knelt before him, prioritizing his people
over his ego.
He was the last King in the North until the
secession of the North and the Riverlands
in the War of the Five Kings and the coronation
of Robb Stark.
House Stark ruled as Kings in the North stretching
back into the mists of time, before written
history began six thousand years ago, when
the Andals invaded all of southern Westeros.
When the Andals arrived, the Stark Kings in
the North were already ruling at Winterfell.
According to legend, the first King in the
North was Brandon Stark, better known as Bran
the Builder, who lived eight thousand years
ago. According to legends, he led the forces
of the North in the War for the Dawn against
the White Walkers and built the Wall to guard
against their return, and also began construction
of Winterfell. The Kings in the North were
successfully able to fend off the Andals from
invading, holding the line of the Neck at
the choke point of Moat Cailin. As a result,
the North remained the only independent kingdom
of the First Men. The North would be an independent
kingom until Aegon the Conqueror comes with
his sisters and their dragons, and the unfortunate
Stark King who would rule the North at this
time happened to be Torrhen Stark. Let's tell
the tale of the King Who Kneeled.
After the riverlands and Storm's End had fallen
under the control of Aegon the Conqueror,
Torrhen Stark called his banners. He was aware
that, due to the vast distance of the North,
it would take a long time to assemble his
army. After the Field of Fire, which was the
pivotal battle that decided the result of
the War of Conquest in which Kings Mern Gardener
of the Reach and Loren Lannister of the Rock
faced the invading Aegon the Conqueror on
the open field. The two kings combined the
armies of both the richest Kingdom and the
most populous Kingdom, terming it the "Iron
Fist". Their total force numbered 60,000 men.
In contrast, Aegon's army was outnumbered
by five to one. The battle was fought on a
wide field in the Reach. However, Aegon the
Conqueror unleashed his three dragons against
the enemy army. Four thousand men burned alive
that day, including King Mern himself. King
Loren, instead, bent the knee to the Targaryen
warlord. He was thus appointed Lord Paramount
of the Westerlands and Warden of the West.
With the death of King Mern, House Gardener,
which had ruled the Reach since the time of
the First Men, became extinct. House Tyrell,
the hereditary stewards of the Gardeners,
then surrendered Highgarden to Aegon. In return,
Aegon raised Harlen Tyrell, the head of the
family, to Lord Paramount of the Reach and
Warden of the South. While at Highgarden,
Aegon I learned that Torrhen had crossed the
Neck and entered the riverlands, leading an
army of thirty thousand men. Torrhen amassed
his army and marched to meet the Targaryen
warlord. Aegon I abandoned his plans to march
south, and at once started his way north,
racing ahead of his army on Balerion. Both
Rhaenys and Visenya Targaryen, as well as
all the lords who had bent the knee to Aegon
after Harrenhal and the Field of Fire, were
sent word of this movement. So when Torrhen
reached the banks of the Trident, he found
a host of forty-five thousand men and three
dragons waiting for him. After seeing Aegon's
dragons and his massive host, Torrhen realized
the war was already lost. Even without dragons,
Torrhen Stark and his northerners were outnumbered,
but there was no doubt he would give a good
fight against those odds but when he saw three
dragons of Aegon the Conqueror, he spent the
entire night with his generals thinking of
what his next and perhaps his final move as
the King in the North should be. Torrhen's
scouts had reported seeing the ruins of Harrenhal,
and Torrhen had heard accounts of the Field
of Fire as well. Some of his lords urged him
to attack, but he realized that a similar
fate would await him, if he tried to force
a crossing. Others of his lords urged the
King of the North to fall back to Moat Cailin,
to make his stand there. Torrhen's bastard
half-brother, Brandon Snow, offered to cross
the Trident at dark, to kill the dragons.
At the end, Torrhen did send his half-brother
Brandon Snow to Aegon's camp, but not to kill
Aegon's dragons, but to treat with Aegon.
The whole night, messages went back and forth,
and the next morning, Torrhen crossed the
Trident, where he kneeled and laid his crown
at the feet of Aegon I Targaryen, and swore
fealty. In exchange for his life, and the
lives of the Northmen, Torrhen Stark swore
fealty to House Targaryen. Instead of fighting,
he chose to bend the knee and surrendered
his crown.
In return for Torrhen's submission, Aegon
allowed House Stark to continue ruling the
North as they had for thousands of years,
but as vassals of the Iron Throne. They held
the titles of Lord Paramount of the North,
Lord of Winterfell, and Warden of the North.
The Starks thus retained their ancient positions
and traditions. Ever since, Torrhen is known
as the King Who Kneeled. It's unknown what
Aegon did with Torrhen's crown. The Inn of
the Kneeling Man later arose where Torrhen
had bent the knee.
After Torrhen's surrender, the Company of
the Rose, a sellsword company, was formed
by men and (according to some accounts) women
from the North who refused to bend the knee
to Aegon I Targaryen. These men and women
willingly chose exile across the Narrow Sea.
Torrhen's sons did not agree with the Targaryen
rule. Some of them spoke of rebelling, and
raising the Stark banner. Whether Torrhen
gave his consent or not is unknown. No rebellions
by House Stark are known thus far. Lord Torrhen's
daughter was married to Ronnel Arryn, Lord
of the Eyrie. This marriage had been arranged
by Queen Rhaenys Targaryen as an attempt to
knit the new realm together. There are letters
at the Citadel which suggest that Lord Stark
only agreed to this match after much protest,
and that his sons had refused to attend the
wedding. Lord Ronnel would be killed early
in the reign of King Aenys I Targaryen by
his own brother, Jonos. It’s unknown whether
Torrhen's daughter was still alive at this
point. Torrhen was entombed in the crypts
of Winterfell after his death.
Three centuries later, Torrhen's descendant,
Ned Stark was amongst the rebel lords against
Aegon the Conqueror's descendant Aerys the
Mad King during Robert's Rebellion, in which
the Targaryen dynasty was deposed and Robert
crowned as the new king. Although some Northerners
sneer at Torrhen as "the king who knelt",
his descendants, the Starks, argue that Torrhen
"saved thousands of lives that day" and that
his critics forget that they are alive today
because of him. King Torrhen is mentioned
a few times in Game of Thrones for kneeling
down to Aegon and his dragons. The most significant
mention of the King Who Knelt was in season
7. When Jon Snow appears before Daenerys Targaryen
on Dragonstone,
the latter scoffs when Ser Davos Seaworth
presents Jon as the King in the North and
declares that the last person who held that
title was Torrhen Stark, who bent the knee
to her ancestor, Aegon the Conqueror, using
Torrhen's declaration of loyalty in perpetuity
to try and persuade Jon into confirming the
North's fealty to House Targaryen and abandoning
the King in the North title. King in the North
(feminine equivalent being Queen in the North)
is the title given to the ruler of the North
during its time as an independent kingdom,
before and after the coming of the Targaryens.
A title also used for the rulers of the North
was the "Kings of Winter". During the opening
stages of the War of the Five Kings, Lord
Robb Stark was proclaimed as the new King
in the North by his bannermen, the first in
300 years after Torrhen Stark. The "Kingdom
of the North" came to a temporary end after
the Red Wedding when Roose Bolton, who conspired
with House Frey and House Lannister, initiated
a massacre of the northern army and personally
stabbed Robb Stark through the heart. However,
the "Kingdom of the North" was reestablished
after a short few years under the Bolton rule,
when the Starks led by Jon Snow and Sansa
Stark later gathered an army of Northern houses
still loyal to House Stark, the Free Folk,
and the Knights of the Vale and retook Winterfell
from the Boltons. With the Boltons defeated,
Jon Snow was proclaimed the new King in the
North, reasserting the North's independence
from the Iron Throne. The "Kingdom of the
North" came to a temporary end once again
when Jon bent the knee to Queen Daenerys Targaryen
in order to gain her full support in the Great
War. Like Torrhen Stark, Jon Snow bent the
knee to save his people. After the death of
Daenerys Targaryen, Sansa Stark declared independence
from the Iron Throne and herself the Queen
in the North and thus the "Kingdom in the
North" was reestablished once again. Her brother
Bran Stark became the ruler of the Six Kingdoms.
300 years after Torrhen Stark knelt to Aegon
Targaryen, now Aegon's descendant Jon Snow
who's real name is Aegon kneeled down to Torrhen's
descendant Bran. All of this is part of the
Targaryen history and the upcoming Game of
Thrones prequel, House of the Dragon is based
on the Targaryen history.
We are bound for an epic journey starting
in 2022 which is when the first episode of
the Game of Thrones prequel airs. Thank you
so much for watching, hope you enjoyed this
video and if you did make sure to give it
a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in the
next one, peace!